[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle so we're
here this is where AFI Fashion Week is
going to be African fashion
international you ready I'm ready are
you ready let's go
with
[Music]
my two brothers are bird here good
morning it is 5:30 early in the morning
and we're on the road to Johannesburg
I'm gonna do a photo shoot and it's a
very cloudy rainy day but let's do this
and the kid is with me you're gonna hang
out a little bit today let's go
[Music]
so look at that taxi in South Africa man
didn't care about the rules he just skip
the red light again exactly they're the
worst drivers traffic lights are not
working you find out a lot here in South
Africa
[Music]
[Applause]
so you're gonna do the makeup
[Music]
[Music]
darn hair makeup just done this is the
clothes that we're gonna wear today I
was shooting for camera today that's the
brand so let's get this going
[Music]
so this is the studio
sneak Boulton studio here in Janice Berg
very good photographer
taking a quick coffee break here right
now so I told you guys we're doing kevro
today right but the brand we're actually
doing is Barron company name is Cairo
but this brand is for Baron now they do
not supply these clothes to people who
want to buy it they supply to companies
that went by the clothes and then put
their own branding on it so resellers
it's quite interesting anyway really
good studio because they give us some
coffee right before we start so good
let's continue to shoot
[Music]
all right so sometimes they do single
shots with the outfit and then we do
couple shots as well and I'll put a
couple shots
this is Kirsty by the way then they're
gonna do some shots of her as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we are having a lunch time
right now everybody's chilling a little
bit burger fries checking out some
photos so this is the kitchen here at
the studio no kitchen is complete if you
don't have coffee and they have caught
so that's good
all right so break is over let's start
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right whenever I'm done with my job
this is what I do the hair
[Music]
okay it's been a long day let's see the
road let's go home
so the photoshoot is done we're a little
bit tardes now we have to drive back
home in traffic so let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to Japan
[Music]